hi my name is Dylan Tracy at this point
if you guys have seen the either the
keynote by Stephen Wolfram this morning
or the the other keynote by tomm welcome
Jones this morning you had some exposure
to the cloud and you may even have
played with it a little bit yourself
already using a free counter or
something else the purpose of this talk
is to give you a little bit more
in-depth exposure to what the data
science platform is and is going to be
and how the workflow is going to work so
I'll talk very briefly about how this
data science platform fits in with the
other cloud offerings that we have and
we'll have why you might want to do data
science in the cloud in the first place
why that's a good thing and then I'll go
through a few concrete examples to show
you what the workflow looks like ok so
earlier this summer we launched the the
programming cloud Stephen Wolfram
mentioned this mentioned this this
morning the emphasis in that cloud
platform is is on deployments on on
prototyping team collaboration managing
your deployments counting the money
rolls in and cetera and then late in the
summer early in the fall we launched
Mathematica online the idea behind this
one is to extend the Mathematica desktop
experience into the cloud so that the
data science platform is in this is in
the stable it's in this portfolio of
stuff and the emphasis here is going to
be on this sort of bread and butter data
science workflow import something
analyze it publish a result and i'll
show you concretely how that works so on
the on the upstream end you're going to
have data that could be structured or
unstructured it could be sitting in a
database it could be sitting in a file
it could be being updated in real-time
it could be static you're going to bring
it into the Wolfram system where you'll
be able to leverage some semantic
interpretations on the data and you'll
do your welcome language customizations
work up your visualizations and so on
and then on the downstream and you go
through a CDF templating step well you
can produce a customized document often
with interactive elements that you can
get in front of a decision maker all
right so why would you want to do data
science in the cloud I think the answer
has something to do with accessibility
and
and reach so we can think by analogy a
little bit you you if you have not yet
yourself played with the idea of an API
function you you met you may have seen
Stephen Wolfram do it this morning so so
functions are now fluid things you can
not only you cannot not only write and
execute them in your desktop environment
but you can cloud deploy them and then
when once you do that they execute in
the cloud once that happens so so for
example here's a I deployed an API
function yesterday that returns a map of
a country here this one is returning a
map of Italy this request is coming from
my browser the computation is being done
in the cloud and the response is being
served back to my browser my browser
doesn't know what technology stack is
running up in the cloud it doesn't care
it just makes an HTTP request and gets a
result so that has the effect of sort of
democratizing computation right so 20
years ago or even a few months ago if I
give you a piece of Wolfram language
code and I told you to execute it for me
you it would have been an acceptable
excuse to say I don't have athletica but
that excuse doesn't exist anymore
because I can publish myself that stuff
as an api function and you haven't you
have a browser right so the something
similar is happening to computable
documents so these these you know
desktop notebooks that we know in love
with all their wonderful interactive
elements now that they are now that they
are usable in an unaugmented zero
configuration web browser there's an
analogous phenomenon happening where
where the the access to results is being
democratized and this this solves a very
serious problem in data science or
closed at gatherings like this one I've
had many conversations with people like
you who have done marvelous analyses
worked up these notebooks doing all
kinds of wonderful things and you say
well what happened how did this play out
in your organization what kind of change
took place and and then and then the
person you're talking to you says well
my boss doesn't have Mathematica and you
say well couldn't he and solve the CDF
browser plugin and they say well IIT
wouldn't let us do that and then you say
oh and the conversation gets it so
that's happened enough times
that I'm has it's happened enough time
said I'm excited about about solving
this problem and I think that's that
sort of one of the killer apps of the
killer features are doing data science
in the cloud so let's let's play with
some real data so here here's some real
data these this this is a spreadsheet of
bigger bigger bigger this is a
spreadsheet of house utilities that i
keep on my house it goes back it's
there's monthly data that goes back a
few years and it's just a simple
rectangle of data with with half a dozen
columns thats kept in a in a cloud
spreadsheet and and here's the URL for
it so i'm going to import this data into
my desktop session I not only imported
it but I semantically imported it so
this is a new function in version 10 you
may have gotten a glimpse of it this
morning so this is not only going to
take care of the mechanics of you know
tearing apart the file and getting it
into into the wolfram system for me but
it's also going to attempt to recognize
entities in the file so this just took
in a raw CSV it was just text but it
still managed to recognize the dates as
dates that's what these funny yellow
orange boxes are on the left and then
fields that contained dollar amounts are
marked as having units okay so this is
taking a lot of the sort of work today
staying out of out of doing data science
these are the kinds of things you used
to have to do by hand but you don't have
to anymore all right this thing that's
being returned is a data set with a
capital D and they're all kinds of funny
queries that you can do on it that's
sort of its own conversation that's its
own topic just just as a very very basic
example i'm going to show you this this
command will extract two columns and
then give them to a visualization
function and then this will show you my
electricity usage in kilowatt-hours
going back for a few years okay that's
all in the desktop I'm going to switch
to the cloud now okay so this is what
the without magnify well so this is what
the front page of the data science
platform looks like these big red
buttons across the top are quick starts
for very common workflows getting data
in from a file that you have in the
cloud getting data in from a file that
you have on your desktop getting data in
from a URL we have data in a URL so
let's let's go through that let's let's
duplicate this desktop workflow in the
cloud so I'm clicking import data from
URL going to paste this URL here and
when I click continue the platform is
going to make a notebook for me that is
seeded with some code to help me start
my analysis okay so this is a normal
this is a normal Mathematica notebook
it's a normal Mathematica notebook in
the cloud and all the things that you're
used to doing in a in a notebook can be
done these buttons this is a template
notebook which is which is a special
kind of it's an augmented kind of
notebook these buttons across the top
allow me to place and control the
behavior of template variables these
template variables can be filled with
whatever I want to fill them with when I
generate a customized document from this
template and this is useful for
customized reporting at the downstream
end I but at any rate the same semantic
import that you just saw happened on the
desktop can now happen in the cloud and
the kind of visualizations that we do on
the desktop can also happen
in the cloud
okay so what you're seeing here is is
that is the corresponding cloud
operation to what we just did on the
desktop and here's the corresponding
visualization to what we just did on the
desktop so this is not yet a very
compelling report but let's pretend that
it is and let's deploy it so I'm going
to press this big red deploy button and
click automated report and then this GUI
pops up and it's got all kinds of levers
and knobs that I can twiddle like the
output format and recipie Pillai want to
receive copies of this report and what
schedule I want to run it on let's say I
want to run this again by utilities bill
once a month so let's run this late in
the month and I click create ok now this
template along with along with some
other things is bundled up into this
into this into this entity on the on the
server and it now appears in my reports
listing in the sidebar here it's this
one here because I didn't give it a name
I if I want to if I want it to run now I
don't have to wait for the end of the
month I'm going to click this little
gear menu and click run report now when
I do that the server is somewhere up in
the cloud a server is grinding into
action a kernel is being launched this
template is being applied a log file is
being generated the resulting document
is produced it's archived and it's sent
to all the people who are listed as
recipients for the document and that
yeah here it is so if I click this link
in my notification email it should open
the resulting generated document in the
cloud ok good so there's my report as I
say that's not so compelling yet but
imagine if I worked on that problem for
a couple of hours okay so I spent some
more time doing more sophisticated
visualisations I could be working on the
desktop and uploading the uploading the
template I could be working right in the
cloud interface and let's say after a
couple hours I came up with this ok so
this is working on the same data and you
can see my semantic import things have
gone a little bit more sophisticated on
doing some road deduplication for cases
where the utilities company made a
mistake you can glimpse um visualization
functions in here some dateless plots
here's some histograms some paired
histograms here's some forecasting using
more sophisticated stuff like time
series model fit in time series forecast
and when I'm happy I can't evaluate this
just as I would a normal notebook but it
gets compelling to other people when I
deploy it as a as an automated report so
again I can go through this through this
GUI press create get a report in my in
my in my sidebar and ask it to run now
if I wanted to while we're waiting for
that to chug I think I can show you
I think I can show you the results of a
previous run let's see
yeah yeah okay so here these these
orange Peaks are my gas usage in the
winter and these blue Peaks are my
electricity usage in the summer and here
we've got some distributions of my
kilowatt hour and thurm's usage and here
they are broken out by season and here's
some forecasting here's my combined gas
and electricity usage here it is
projected out 12 months using a seasonal
adjusted its ARIMA model and you know
here's what I'm on the hook for this
this this fall in winter so there are
all kinds of directions that you could
take this in you may want to compare how
the prediction from last month matched
up to the actuality for this valent and
so on but we've already been able to
cover the the workflow from one end to
the other so this is a document that
could be that can be consumed that can
be put in front of other people so we
went we went from one end the raw data
to this pretty quickly and the hope is
that these deployments of these
automated reports will be pretty
lightweight you can do lots of them very
quickly and and and the turnover for
them will be will be short okay I'm
going to flip back to the desktop now
all right I want to show you a little
bit more about what you can do with with
with semantic semantically imported data
so this is a cute data set this is a
tree inventory done by the city of
Champaign so here are the columns that
you get you get a tree species in a
common name and then you get some some
stats about the size and shape of the
tree and you get a location you get a
latitude longitude pair all right so I'm
going to semantically import this data
set this time I'm going to give the
cement the interpreter a hint that the
first column contains a plant okay try
that again that the first column
contains a plant and the interpreter
will attempt to a to assign a plant
species to that column
once that semantic import finishes i'll
give you a glimpse of what the raw the
raw results of the semantic import look
like once again we're on the desktop
here there's no cloud involved yet
okay so if you look in the in the
left-hand column here you see that some
of these in cases where there actually
was a tree and not at a vacant site or
something you get an entity back that in
this entity has curated metadata
attached to it this isn't it this is an
idea brought in from wolfram alpha and
this this this metadata is available to
you in your analysis think and and can
facilitate the kind of these uh this
so-called knowledge-based analytics also
notice that the the position has been
wrapped the latitude longitude pair has
been recognized as a logical understreet
pair and has been wrapped in geo
position this will make it this will
make mapping applications easier as
we'll see okay so to give you an idea of
the kind of weird right now scope to
give you the idea of the kinds of things
that that knowledge no alpha is
complaining that that knowledge based
analytics gives you gives you access to
if I ask for the number of properties
associated with the red maple i get i
get nothing i get about 150 and so for
example i can ask for the foliage colour
of the red maple and this may or may not
come back
as green okay so let's do something
similar in the cloud so here's a
template that I worked up to hear that I
worked up in the cloud to look at the
same trees data set so here you can do
me you can see me doing the semantic
import of the of the trees data set I'm
going to do a little bit of munching on
it and then I'm going to do some data
sciency stuff where I look at like the
top five most common trees and then I'm
going to you see this Geographics here
this is a super fun feature new in
mathematica 10 that's going to do some
mapping of the tree species I'm going to
zero in on the ash trees that I'm going
to isolate one of the species and look
at them when I'm happy with this I'll do
the same thing that I showed you before
deploy automated report create and I'll
and and get a and get it and get this
tree template report ask it to run now
while we're waiting for that I'll show
you I'll show you the results of a
previous run okay so here's here here
are the you know the five most common
trees in the data set these thumbnails
of the tree species came for free with
the metadata attached to the entities I
didn't have to go look that up I didn't
have to do any work at all it was just a
property attached to the entities so
that came for free here's a push pin map
of the sampling of the tree locations
color-coded by species where are we we
are I guess at that intersection a lot
of a lot of distinct tree species so
this is a little bit busy if I isolate
the ash trees things get a little bit
more manageable so all of the ash tree
the ash trees in Illinois and many parts
the united states are being eaten by
these these are emerald ash borers that
are thought to come over from thought to
have come over from east asia and
packing material this this dataset did
not contain data on sick trees but I was
I found myself wishing that it did
because that would have been neat so I
made up some data simulated some so
here's some simulated sick trees based
on a two-dimensional distribution and
then I colored the sick trees red okay
so you can see this outbreak this this
ash borer infestation west of I 57 in
this map down here so you
if you work for the city or something it
would be nice to have this in your email
every Monday right in fact for the the
data science course that I taught
yesterday morning I worked up an example
where we use the machine learning
functions to classify functions to
classify to identify candidate sick
trees in the rest of the city based on
the characteristics of the ones were
actually sick ok so if provided that
approach actually makes sense if you can
predict vulnerability to ash borers
based on the kinds of things that
arborists measure and these kinds of
data sets then that would be a real
labor saver because you know the city
only has so many trucks in some in so
many arbors to send around so could be
an interesting application ok so
everything that you've seen so far in
the cloud has been kind of gooey centric
but we think very hard about language
design and it's it's generally the case
that everything you can do with with the
web GUI has a corresponding language
equivalent so these automated reports
these bundles of stuff that executes up
in the clouds are known in the languages
document generators and I'll show you
briefly how these work from the language
level so here I am back in the desktop
let me show you a very simple template
ok here's a here's a super super simple
document template that has one slot in
it for an author I'm going to deploy an
automated report using that template
from here from the desktop ok so that's
a one-liner that's this it uses this
cloud to play a team that we used to
cloud apply everything I'm going to
specify a document generator with that
template and minimally that's all you
need you don't even necessarily need a
schedule so I'm going to deploy that now
ok so this that thinks being bundled up
and sent to the cloud right now once
that's up there I might want to trigger
it to run without waiting for its
schedule in this case it doesn't have
one so i have to trigger it if I expect
it to run at all and there are two ways
that I can do that I can do that in a
blocking way or I wait for the result or
I could do that in a non blocking way
where I let it go do its thing as if it
had been triggered by its natural
calendar trigger and and then wait for
an email notification or go check it
later so here I will I will evaluate it
in a blocking way
so right now evaluate evaluation of that
thing took place in the cloud I got back
a cloud object and if I click on this
this should be the document that was
generated by that generator there it is
okay so too so to go back to that
utilities example if you wanted to
deploy that from the desktop without
going through that web GUI if you want
it that's just that's that's just this
it's a one-liner here this one has a
scheduled monthly so as I say the
intention here the hope is that these
deployments will be very lightweight
like here at Wolfram we have a we have
an enterprise data warehouse and you
know there's a team that manages that
manages it and works with it and
requesting a report to be set up in it
is it's not a heavyweight process but
there's some process there and the hope
is that this will be much more
maneuverable right that I could deploy
ten of these in the morning if I wanted
to with you know slight variations for
four different people and here I'll tell
this one to run asynchronously just for
the heck of it I I'll leave you with a
I'll give you a glimpse of a more
complicated example so here's a template
for a stock report let's give you a bit
more sense of what you can do all right
so this this stock report is fed with a
bunch of tickers you give it a list of
tickers that you want to stock report on
and then it uses the financial data
packet to look at some properties on
those instruments and then it gives you
back it gives you back little
interactive widgets that let you explore
those properties over the past the time
series of those properties over the past
2 m days okay this makes use of a
template feature called the repeating
block that allows a template to handle a
variable number of elements so i could
give this template one instrument or
five instruments or 50 ok now let's
let's say let's say i'm working a
financial company and somebody says to
me i want a daily report on the
performance over the past 30 days of the
five stocks in the trucking industry
that had the highest trading volumes in
the previous day do it
right that by nature you don't know what
properties you're going to be reporting
on until until that day right so this is
a case where the document generator
itself needs to be able to need to need
some intelligence it needs to be able to
decide what to fill the template with at
the time the document is being generated
okay so we call that case driver logic
driver logic can live in inline code it
could live in its own script or can even
live in its own notebook here I put it
in its own function so this driver this
driver is going to use financial data to
look up the members of the trucking
industry sector then it's going to look
up the volume yesterday and it's going
to sort them and take the top end and
then it's going to it's going to go
about preparing the other slots for
filling the template with okay the
actual deployment of the document
generator itself is still pretty simple
we're just specifying the template and a
schedule and also the driver logic okay
so I'm going to deploy that and run it
this one hits the financial data packet
pretty hard so it takes a couple minutes
to run and in the meantime I think I can
show you the results of a previous I'll
wait a bit for that to come maybe it'll
maybe it'll show up before the end of
the so that's the so that's the that's a
glimpse of the DSP workflow and and it's
it's a how it fits into this import
analyze published paradigm you seen data
come in and you see these documents come
out I've shown you how the semantic
interpretation helps enable it sort of
streamlines some aspects of the analysis
and brings in some stuff that you might
not even have thought of doing otherwise
very importantly doing data science in
the cloud solves the dissemination
problem which in my opinion in my
experience has been the the biggest
single obstacle to getting the Wolfram
stock into people's organizations for
doing data science also I want to leave
you at the point that the the cloud can
be used in a standalone way but it also
hybridizes pretty naturally with the
desktop so these kind of these cloud
deploys that you see we do re easily
managed if you if you do data science
you if you do data science and even now
without the cloud you probably have
learned to maintain a mental model of
the kinds of things that are happening
in memory and the kinds of things are
happening on disk and you say well this
is a high latency operation and this is
a low latency operation dealing with the
cloud sort of adds another layer to that
well this is happening in the cloud and
this is happening locally but it's sort
of the same idea and and and and and the
platform sort of works naturally in both
in both modes I'd be happy to
demonstrate this is very quick i
understand i'd be happy to demonstrate
more detail aspects of this that that
you would like to see more of please you
know grabby wherever you see mirror on
the around the conference any of these
other team members whom you meet here
will also be happy to speak to you about
it thank you